five of the best from magnetic
magnificent mobis the current world
champion and considered maybe to be the
best player of all time I'll let you
guys discuss that below make sure you
like and subscribe to this channel and
the video and can you spot Magnus's move
can you play like the world champion I
doubt it you know I really do doubt it
but you might surprise me on to example
number one in this first example Magnus
was pretty much getting out of his pram
only 12 years old and he showed his
flair for the game in this position
after the move h6 attack in the night
most 12 year olds would retreat that
night but not Magnus can you spot the
move do Queen takes a 7 out of the blue
a brilliant example of taking advantage
of your opponent's weak back rank and
this move offering the Queen wins the
game in Sun style
not bad for twelve-year-old for example
if the rook takes the Queen Magnus gets
his chest hood of her out and he sucks
up those pieces rook takes e8 check only
one move Queen to d8 and now it's a
Hoover job rook takes the 8th check King
takes Knight takes aresome check King
moves Knight takes 8 shape thank you
very much and in the game after this
amazing move Queen takes a 7 black
decided to play rook b8 but this did not
help blacks cause because of the move
Queen takes b8 and the same thing
happens the rook comes flying in and it
mocks up a load of pieces ok black still
has the Queen but white has the two
rooks and a winning game which Magnus
went on to win 12 years old
claw and my jealous
a little a little we move on to the
second example and Magnus has grown up a
little bit by now and he's playing the
fantastic player tax on the rich cook we
have this position where Grizz chuck has
just played rook takes b8 now Magnus has
some scary-looking pawns but with his
next move he makes them even scarier can
you see the stunning move that Magnus
now move licks onto the board
Bishop to a6 and this is just the
brilliant visual move we're trying to
get rid of the porn on b7 so we then
have free space invaders
boo-boo-boo-boo-boo trying to reach the
touchdown rank of the eighth rank
turning themselves into fluffy little
Queens and the point is if that bishop
is taken well now a move such as d7 or
c6 would eventually lead to queening for
example d7 Bishop f6 the spot that c6
these spacing Vaden pawns are too strong
Grizz trip tried Bishop f6 immediately
to cover one of those queening squares
but Magnus now forces the issue with
Bishop takes b7 getting rid of the brick
in the wall rook takes b7 and now c6
here they come and now after rook takes
b6 the rook plays a very subtle move
rook c1 and this pawn can not be stopped
this is even better than going c7
because of rook c6 and the route gets
behind that poor but after rook to c1
Bishop takes b2 is played and after d7
grid strip resigned touchdown is
inevitable and a beautiful beautiful
concept from Magna Steyr on to example
none free well this is taken up from
another game where Magnus was very young
against his fellow compatriot gamma
Magnus with the black pieces and Hammer
now plays rook to e1 what shocking move
did Magnus now play to force a
resignation Queen to h5 check a
brilliant idea and this is an example of
what is coined the Anastasia check mate
the knight controls g1 so after the
Queen has taken the rook is now free to
swing over delivering the final punch
simply stunning a lovely trip mate
example number 4 has a bit of sense of
humor about it in this position Magnus
with the black pieces is playing some
gay Carrie aking of Russia also known as
the carjacking man and in this position
Sergei has just played rook takes h7
what makes this even more amazing is
that it's a blind fold game now what
move did Magnus now play this might be
one that you guys at home can find it's
something we're taught to do at a very
early stage of the game castles King
side is one of those ones where you
think what can you do that the route was
on h8 what's going on and I like this
move because it has something quite
pretty about it quite unique night is
now attacked and if the knight moves of
course we play King takes h7 winning the
rook and there's nothing else that white
can really do here if rook to h6 we can
still capture the night and after rook
g6 which seems like it wins a piece back
King to h7 rook takes Bishop and now the
back rank is White's weakness rook to f1
checkmate so example I would say a
little bit of sexy luma route takes h7
castles King side you don't see that
often this last example is very famous
it's from the last game of the 2016
World Championship match and again we
have Magnus Carlsen with the white
pieces against Sergey carry a king the
next move played here won
Magnus the World Championships and it
was probably the best ever move to win a
World Championships the story goes that
Magnus said to his opponents before the
game
I am your nemesis
a righteous infliction of retribution
manifested by an appropriate agents
personified in this case by me a
blooming good chess player well that's
not actually true but you know maybe
where that comes from
so what move did Magnus now play in
actually looks like he might be in a bit
of trouble because he's threatened with
a number of checkmate but a stunning
move now comes up Queen to h6 check a
beautiful Queen sacrifice kind of out of
the blue
not even capturing a piece but opening
up a way for either the rook on c8 or
the rook on f5 for example if King takes
Queen the HH square is now free so route
to h8 is checkmate
if pawn takes Queen then black weakens
his 7th rank so rook takes f7
is checkmate what a brilliant way to
finish a world championship match well I
hope you enjoyed those five brilliant
examples discussed below what was your
favorite one and remember to like the
video and subscribe to chess comm hope
you enjoyed it good bye for now
have Leo look at these videos
[Music]